hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna
just checking it on you just check it in
and see how things are going in your
[Music]
shout out to all the [ __ ] people who
you know ran around and did whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted to do way to hit the
reset button there fuckos way to [ __ ]
everyone over you macho [ __ ] without
your massage [ __ ] [ __ ] goin nice
going and now what are you gonna say
that the information they're giving us
is [ __ ] I don't know what are you
gonna do what are you gonna I will tie I
will say this I will say this this is
helping me with all of my you know
conspiracy theory ways though when I
watch people when you actually have you
ever been like on the inside and known
what the [ __ ] is going on you know and
then you listen you watch people just
take footage and then they click it and
they add it to this and they go over
there and then they got this whole
[ __ ] story line with air-quote
evidence yeah I noticed that this week I
noticed that this weekend people just
like I saw this thing right that dude on
that that 70s show right and somebody
you say get arrested for [ __ ] what
they call it forcible rape right this is
how dumb people are in the [ __ ]
internet and I'm one of them that's why
I don't leave comments you know better
to remain silent than open your mouth
and remove all doubt right so people
once they see forcible rape people like
as opposed to wet enjoyable rain please
don't use word say food super please do
that like there's a nicer kind of rape
and then finally a lawyer chimes in he
goes no forcible as opposed to statutory
or coerced and then he broke it's just a
different you know I would imagine you
could just use your words and threaten
somebody you could drug somebody and
then there's like
what do you call it the consensual but
the other person wasn't of age so that's
all that was and all these people got
all it got it right up on this social
justice warrior horses and started
[ __ ] going off on the air quote
idiots right so when somebody actually
has the [ __ ] knowledge steps in to
correct them then these [ __ ] go oh my
bad my bad sorry you're right I got a
little emotional there sorry no nothing
it's nothing they just they just [ __ ]
wander off to the next thing that's
trending on [ __ ] social media and
then what do they do they open their
[ __ ] pie holes and more [ __ ] comes
out it's almost like listening to this
podcast see what he did
yeah acts like he's gonna be on his high
horse isn't he actually and then the end
he's down there in the mud just like
everybody else well I'm having a very
exciting week I rearranged my little
podcast studio here very excited I got
all kinds of [ __ ] I got more goddamn
footballs in my [ __ ] house than
George Blanda
one of the great kickers quarterbacks of
all [ __ ] time I can see one two three
of them and I'm not counting all the
ones that I got from Sports Illustrated
when the Patriots won there's six Super
Bowl titles there I'm finally arranging
all this [ __ ] memorabilia and all this
stuff I'm gonna get it all in the closet
right just like my emotions and maybe a
little mood lighting in here turn it
into like my morning Greg Brady got the
[ __ ] upstairs attic you know they're
not glass is their shades right he had
the [ __ ] you'd walk through those
beads remember that [ __ ] back in the
back in the day it was cool to not have
a door you just had beads hanging down
from the door jamb for like you know
like walking through a [ __ ] NFL
cornerbacks braids you just you just
kind of he parted the Seas you know and
then you just came walking in but person
could clearly see into it it was
considered really cool so I would
imagine by the time they did it on the
Brady Bunch
it was over Jesus
George Blanda the Brady Bunch why don't
you come to this side of the [ __ ]
turn of the last century all right sorry
I just been living in the past you know
finished my book on Lou the tow Groza I
got a book on Bobby Lane I'm gonna read
now and I'm [ __ ] you know [ __ ] CDC
what does that stand for can't determine
the cause you know at first I was
annoyed now I'm just thinking like you
know what let him let him [ __ ] just
roll around with each other maybe
they'll all kill each other off can you
imagine that imagine if this is just a
giant experiment oh he's going
conspiracy theory you know what if this
was all just a like all the world
leaders somehow all got on the same page
and just said listen there's too many
people all right we're not gonna be able
to make them stop [ __ ] okay
they're gonna keep running their yaps
talking [ __ ] taking their dicks out
sticking them in the pudding right and
they're gonna just keep making more
people all right now we need to get rid
of most of them okay but we want to make
sure we just get rid of the dumb ones so
they release a virus okay knowing that
the formula is this the first couple
weeks everybody's gonna be [ __ ]
scared all right
there'll be some deniers and then
eventually everybody will get on board
and then they'll get cabin fever and
then what's gonna happen is with
politics with the ego with paranoia and
all of that [ __ ] the mouth breathers are
gonna come out of their houses they're
gonna go down to the parks they're gonna
start playing frisbee you know cuz it's
all because what they're gonna do is
they're gonna make it about themselves
you know what I mean it's like when
anybody gets like [ __ ] in trouble on
the internet right
at first it's about what it's about and
then immediately it becomes about the
individual like why am I not surprised
or this is me hearing so-and-so [ __ ]
blah blah blood right it's like this
isn't about all of those people sorry
all of those people wander out of their
[ __ ] houses right and they start
skipping down the [ __ ] Street doing
whatever the [ __ ] it and I'm not talking
about the black lives matter because
that [ __ ] you know needed to happen I'm
just talking I'm talking about people
who their cause is themselves those
people you know at first I was annoyed
that they that they started to spike you
know like I had a buddy mine he did a
show in this state he goes dude they
don't even give a [ __ ] they don't even
give a [ __ ] about the coronavirus I was
like dude neither do you
you [ __ ] went there you went in there
now you're gonna play [ __ ] Judge Judy
that ain't how it works there's this and
then they all wander out there and then
they get it right and they get it again
and then it mutates and then it [ __ ]
takes them out okay and then what
they'll have left in the end is a bunch
of smart people who listen to Authority
which is what they want they want smart
people so they could do the jobs they
don't want to do and then and then they
don't have a baby rebelling right bill
no I'm not I'm calling myself a guy that
has enough toys at his house and enough
funnybone money laying around that I can
[ __ ] ride this thing out a little bit
longer you know although I gotta tell
you the with this new kid in in and like
the amount of [ __ ] they a woman buys for
a kid which is great that mean this is
lits like their Super Bowl party for the
next [ __ ] 18 years in [ __ ] Amazon
by the way Amazon you buy a pacifier
they put it in a [ __ ] refrigerator
box so the last two weeks a
okay I put my trash out I have more
trash than I have space in my barrels
and my buddy goes once you get another
barrel I go you don't do that one of the
dumbest things guys do is they buy their
wife a bigger house oh my god you know
we have no more closet space we have
ever what didn't throw this [ __ ] out
don't throw it out give it away to
people you throw it out and ends up in
the ocean and somebody makes a sad video
scuba diving past all your [ __ ] [ __ ]
from your footlocker right you got it
you got it you got it I don't know I
don't know how this works you can't Syst
capitalism we can't [ __ ] sustain this
you got to keep buying this [ __ ] because
there's no place to put it you know when
ever since I've been a kid they always
say they put litter in its place it
which evidently means where the animals
live or where the fish swim just get it
out of our sight so we don't see what
the [ __ ] were doing right and then every
once in a while some tree hugger puts on
of some [ __ ] flip-flops and goes for
a swim and then you see all the [ __ ]
from the I don't know all the way back
to [ __ ] this is think that I'm
[ __ ] over here having gas although I
haven't eaten some bean slightly so who
knows yeah [ __ ] I don't I mean where
I'm going with this [ __ ] you know I I
just I just I don't know these [ __ ]
[ __ ] still walking around it's just
you just like alright you know I'm
trying really hard not to wish my fellow
man a swift and unmasked death anyway
it's been called to my attention that
the the Pentagon are one of these guys
CIA or what I was [ __ ] highfalutin
people and they got the cure man you
know they do they have flat-screen TVs
or even thinner than your [ __ ] skin
they released some video my buddy was
telling me the way they were saying that
they actually confirmed that yet they've
seen [ __ ] flying around that they have
no idea what the [ __ ] it is that's
pretty [ __ ] wild huh what is that I
did like that they didn't shoot it down
it was just some of the best pilots in
the world flying like [ __ ] hundred
million dollar jets like actually
admiring what they were seeing like the
footage that I saw I'm sure they didn't
release this stuff where they were like
I think they had to have at least four
in our country we you know I think with
everybody you got to have the pilots
seem like they can maintain their cool
no matter what they see you know it's
not a good look if people you know
flying a [ __ ] f-18 whatever whatever
number they're up to was it f21
if 36 I have no idea you can't have them
flipping out like William Shatner in
that Twilight Zone episode right so I
mean that's acceptable I think if you
fly for like Delta or something like
that it's acceptable because it's just
like way you have to understand the
maneuverability of what he's flying
although the capabilities are way beyond
what the passenger can comprehend it is
no match and is a sitting duck for any
type of unidentified flying object but
they were just sort of admiring how fast
it's let's flying you know I don't know
how it was 110 not win or some [ __ ] like
that it was I don't know I know what the
[ __ ] they said was all pilot [ __ ] I used
to fly I use the fly
hoping to get back to what I'm starting
to forget how to do [ __ ] you know it's
actually pretty straightforward up-down
left-right petals alright so I mentioned
on the Joe Rogan podcast that I was
going to try to help off the Troubadour
right one of the great live music venues
in the world and I'm trying to you know
they're in a bad way and I just don't
think with these all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] walking around without mass on
that we're gonna have time to do a
[ __ ] stand-up show before things go
south over there so what I'm towing with
the idea I might do a live podcast
they're like back in the day when I did
it a dynasty typewriter and I might just
do one there by myself and I'll tell you
some stories about all the heavy metal
bands that I saw that played in that
venue I'll tell you some stories uh [ __ ]
that I read about rich Steve Martin open
for Richard Pryor they're all that type
of [ __ ] and I don't like like a [ __ ]
idiot
and I'll have a donation button and if
you can donate anything a dollar
anything you can it would be a great
thing but I also understand that
everybody else you know we're so far
into this is very stressed out so I'm
toying with that idea possibly for next
Monday I'm gonna try to make it happen
so try to do something positive as I sit
here talking about my fellow countrymen
dying I would be so great if it was
nobody you knew and they just didn't
cover it and they did just one day they
were just gone you know I think it drive
down the [ __ ] Street arm out the
window the best of the best the smartest
the most OBT let's not set the bar too
high or so I'm not gonna make it you
know from all around the world the
Olympics of human citizens it's you make
the dream team of Olympic us the most
exciting thing going on in my life right
now
oh so anyway I didn't finish this so I
we fill up our [ __ ] trash bin so you
know what you have to do when you fill
up your trash bins either you leave the
trash behind or you have to do you gotta
like sort of sneak out and find some of
your name
trash barrels that aren't filled up
right so that's what I did last night I
made like three [ __ ] trips because
Amazon has the biggest [ __ ] box I
don't know what it is I don't know if
this is like some thing they're trying
to psyche people out I'll make you even
more excited like look up I'm [ __ ]
walking down the streets we've made four
trips and went down and up I tried to
spread it out and I'm walking down the
street and I'm thinking like isn't this
[ __ ] hilarious
alright now I am currently co-starring
in the number one streaming movie in the
world with a bald freckled [ __ ] with an
orange caterpillar on the top of his lip
you can you can google that the number
one movie with the bald guy with an
orange moustache trending right now on
the streaming upload interface whatever
computer should use and I am walking
down the street and up the street with
[ __ ] trash tiptoeing hoping I'm not
going to get caught you know I had
respect for my neighbors where I waited
til it was late at night you know I made
sure I didn't overflow anybody's barrels
I just had to get the trash out of where
I live and to where the animals live
okay and there's a lot of tree huggers
listen to this but you have to
understand okay
they be doing it to us if they could
figure out how to make plastic don't
ever forget that
all right for all you [ __ ]
vegetarians out there man [ __ ] so that's
all I've been doing and I just said this
morning I had my beautiful baby boy a my
my wife dressed him up on this cute
little grey on grey outfit right almost
a mock turtleneck this kid's gonna crush
it man I'm telling you he's gonna crush
it really good-looking kid
so I spent the morning I played with my
daughter and then once my wife got up
and around you know I just I finished
that Lu the toe grows a book and with my
son sleeping on my chest man it was
[ __ ] awesome and I am also officially
done promoting season four of emphasis
for family and I also am done promoting
I mean I'll talk about it but I don't
have to do any more press for the king
of Staten Island which has been crushing
it so I want to thank everybody you guys
took the time to really send me a lot of
nice emails and stuff on on Twitter
about how much you enjoyed both efforts
for family in the king of Staten Island
and it's awesome and it's I really
appreciate it
especially during these difficult times
of the new normal when and when trying
to be more woke and not asleep and
another [ __ ] things that people talk
about other things that people say so I
got us I got to post a picture of the
sport coat that Lou Groza wore when in
1974 when he was inducted into the Pro
Football Hall of Fame I mean it's just
it is I don't know why it went out of
style
I guess cuz everybody was wearing it but
it was just so fun to look at I mean it
was just I want to say it was checkered
I don't know what it was it wasn't
houndstooth but whatever it was it was
[ __ ] amazing let me see this gotta be
some with all the hipsters out there
there's got to be like let me see 1970s
sport coats come on man what do you got
here there's got to be sick Blazers
sport coat men's vintage 70 blazer let's
see this probably just one 70s men disco
blazer style this is when Coke was first
coming in there's like 280 there's two
70s right
there's the early 70s as I call him the
Serpico 70s and then there's the BG 70s
you know before we slow slid into New
Wave 80s into the [ __ ] coke the big
lie Miami Vice 80s right now that was
all done from a total white perspective
of time okay but that's what I am beyond
white bill burr beyond white look at
that baby blue Jesus Christ you can
smell the cigarette smoking all of this
[ __ ] I remember you know like the
classic red green that plaid Scotland
[ __ ] plaid my dad had a three-piece
[ __ ] suit I think he still has it
that was all that material and he used
to wear and there was black in it to see
weird black shoes he would have that
whole [ __ ] plaid thing going on you
know it had what it was predominantly
red in black and it had a little bit of
green and yellow in it you know and then
my dad would wear like a yellow shirt
probably because of that yellow stripe a
loud yellow shirt underneath it into the
vest the whole [ __ ] thing plaid
three-piece suit vintage see if I can
find this [ __ ] thing 1970s people we
are deep into a pandemic I don't know
what you want for me whoa okay that's
some herb tar-like [ __ ] there I just
hate how everybody's got a mocking the
reason why it looks cool in the 70s and
not now is because people are making fun
of it back then people walked around
like they either thought they looked
good or they weren't even questioning
what they were wearing dude look at that
1920 style plaid some badass holy [ __ ]
Gucci's men's retro 5,800 bucks where
the [ __ ] did they get off charging that
kind of money for anything 5,800 bucks I
had to be able to drive across country
in it like it should drive me right no
but that's kind of a low price
come on man this is all a bunch of
[ __ ] young people now I'm gonna see
those [ __ ] people that look like
they're gonna have a heart attack at any
moment
70s plaid suit Jesus Christ now this is
all [ __ ] do you know what the thing
back in the day - what I loved about old
school photos is people didn't know how
to pose you know you know how to pose
rock stars models they knew how to post
now have you [ __ ] douche with the
[ __ ] Instagram you don't I mean
holding the [ __ ] you know they got
the crane shot so you can look at the
new [ __ ] what do you call it what are
those those [ __ ] things that chop
everything up in the kitchen
Pat's no it's an appliance you know
that's the number one place where serial
killers kill people is in the kitchen in
the kitchen that's what happens is
because normally they've killed
everybody around the house but there's
always that person who comes home late
when the serial killer is making a
sandwich and then he usually finishes
them off there right or is it because
they come around dinner or did I just
make all of that up because I still have
another [ __ ] seven minutes to go on
this [ __ ] thing maybe that maybe
that's what it is all right I know
what's going on with me I need to go out
and I need to go for a [ __ ] drive
that's what I need to do I really I
really need to do is run down the
[ __ ] Street a couple of times and
come back up because I have so adjusted
to just staying [ __ ] home then I
don't even leave and and unless it's
late at night if I developed a stutter
during them as in an in it in it unless
it's late at night and I got a bunch of
extra trash I have to throw out like
that was my exercise walking down the
street and then back up and I live on a
street that's just he ever slight little
grade going up that's it you know like
if you had rollerskates and you stood in
front of my house it would be real slow
before the terror built be like whoa hey
okay easy easy easy
that's our go that's the great of my
street if you ever want to come over and
pave it anyway and I think that's all I
got I don't have any advertising you
know why would I have any advertising
you know I mean [ __ ] horrific [ __ ]
that I talk about on this goddamn
podcast yeah so what else you gonna do
today bill I don't know for my birthday
I got a book on mediterranean-style
cooking I'm very excited about so I'm
gonna go with the [ __ ] that I know I'm
gonna start with I'm gonna try to make
some falafels today you know I've got
some chickpeas I got a little [ __ ]
parsley and some cilantro I got some
cucumbers 280 sighs the [ __ ] tomatoes
and pedis gonna give that a little
[ __ ] world I do find it interesting
that I have to somehow know what the
internal temperature of the falafel is
like I need a [ __ ] meat thermometer
for this I just can't believe anybody
worth their salt that makes a [ __ ]
falafel after three times needs a
goddamn thermometer to understand where
the [ __ ] it is right don't you tell just
by help golden brown and isn't delicious
now being [ __ ] hungry and I put on
like five six seven [ __ ] pounds all
that weight I took off and put it on
during the last couple weeks the stress
of my wife you know you know and then I
stayed in the [ __ ] hospital eating
that all that [ __ ] sodium fueled food
for like two three days and then it was
it was my wife's birthday and my
birthday so the sweets was just off the
charts
and I gotta tell you I just put my face
in all of it you know like a big dog
that slobbers all over your [ __ ]
pillow that was me eating I had a [ __ ]
great time doing it you know the sense
of accomplishment is of Lewis losing
weight is so eclipsed by the joy of
putting it on you know you wake up in
the morning your stomach's flat you feel
good about yourself but you don't feel
good like there is not a rush like why
is the sugar rush that you know that's
why that's how people end up eating so
much they just you know
you ever buy something right and IKEA
one of these [ __ ] places and then you
assemble it and then you go to move and
you're like I can't get this out of the
[ __ ] house I need to disassemble this
[ __ ] thing or just leave it you know
the fact that you can do that is a human
being you can walk into a room and start
eating to the point where Bronx Tale now
you can't leave what does that like the
day you go to get up you probably know
it you see its comin and just like when
I'm putting on weight I don't want to
step on the scale like that you you know
that's when your that's when you're
really overeating when your student it
goes from I don't want to step on that
scale to I don't want to try to walk
through that door frame there's
something like psychological like
whatever pain that you're in it's a
combination of that and when Pizza Hut
started putting the cheese in the pizza
you know because I think even some of
the most gluttonous pizza people a lot
of them blew off the crust you know I
always thought was dumb that they just
put the cheese in there he's you might
as well put some [ __ ] sauce in there
too right that was one of the dumb to
two big food down falls in this country
is when they start stop started using
fake sugar right I started using fake
sugar and then all of a sudden Mexico
made better tasting coca-cola than the
United States of America that would be
like if we made like better Mexican food
than Mexico doesn't make any sense
all right coca-cola that's ours all
right you know that [ __ ] that you drink
they can also take rust off the fender
of a [ __ ] car yeah we came up with
that huh jealous
[Laughter]
oh yeah I had a couple of root beer
floats this week I mean I was [ __ ] out
of control but the thing is is I don't
have that thing where I'm gonna keep
going til I can't leave the room that
I'm in you know do you think with open
floor plans so many open floor plans and
now the us learning about Fung Shui that
people will get even fatter because like
this this house is now we're like the
entire one outside wall is glass and
it's just a bunch of like just the whole
[ __ ] thing can open up a herd of
elephants could literally come walking
in if they knew how to duck down
[ __ ] dopes I'm sick of people telling
me how intelligent elephants are if
they're so goddamn smart right how do
you end up working at the circus right
you show me an elephant that becomes a
[ __ ] doctor then I'll set up and
listen alright even the [ __ ] bear can
ride a bicycle there now there's all
this new stuff coming out that's making
me question like eating meat you know
I'm just gonna pause there so all these
[ __ ] people could be there saying
that chickens can count to ten
you know they can they can recognize
like I don't know they can see more
colors than we can and like and there's
something else and then they they know
like they have like 15 different noises
they make so they're actually talking
and they can count but I can only count
up the tent so when you eat a chicken
its it's like eating a two-year-old
person you know and I love kids and I
just don't know if I want to be a part
of that you know what number do you
think chickens need need to learn to
count up to before we stop eating them
there's a good question you know and I'm
willing to bet they're not going to know
the answer because if they had the
intelligence to [ __ ] think of what
the [ __ ] I just said which I can't even
remember at this point I don't think
we'd be eating them you know
I watched an owl and a falcon go at it
over a [ __ ] nest on YouTube the other
day I was at this [ __ ] man this [ __ ]
scary-looking you know they're like the
[ __ ] they're like that mike singletary
of birds those remember mike singletary
XY's when he be across they're in the
[ __ ] quarterback will be all scared
do they do this thing when you start
coming at them and they're like who the
[ __ ] are you they bend do they have a
waist I don't know what that they seven
look like they bend at the waist and
then they they bring out their their
wings and they have their wings like
it's almost like it if their wings could
point down at the floor like if they had
fingers in the middle of the wings right
so they bring them up like your elbows
right bend at the waist do it with me
come on bend your waist and then you
bring your [ __ ] elbows up like that
pointed at the ceiling and then the tail
comes up over the top like a [ __ ]
peacock and then they start doing this
you know this thing with their [ __ ]
head you know that makes them you know
look like they that they would crush it
on one of those dance shows back in the
day you know like one of those movies
you got served think they start going
into that like that's such a cool ass
[ __ ] bird I'm surprised nobody's put
some music to it that's you what usually
happens somebody does like the owl remix
if you guys seen that one where that guy
looks down that shaft and there's like
this [ __ ] owl down there you know and
then there's like there's like three
little owls behind him and this thing
just is looking like you come dead like
you know what's up come on down and see
what the [ __ ] happens by the way I'm
getting tired of these [ __ ] animal
videos where the mother saves the
[ __ ] daughter and it's just like a
mother's strength is [ __ ] that it's
like are you really using this [ __ ]
zebra getting its [ __ ] young zebra
away from the [ __ ] alligator as a way
to [ __ ] you know pump up you and your
[ __ ] SUV and your cloth bags on your
way to your [ __ ] artisan ice cream
store you're not you're not you know how
many mothers do you think would actually
[ __ ] with an alligator if it was coming
near their kid you know there's that
thing when you're running in they could
make another
I know that's not true because when I
watched those videos and I think what
the [ __ ] I would do if any of those
[ __ ] animals
it's just instant death you would just I
know I know exactly what the [ __ ] I
would do an alligator I would [ __ ] I
would jump like you know like in in in
wrestling when they threw somebody off
the ropes and then you do the fly in
[ __ ] body press or whatever the [ __ ]
they caught got I can't remember the
name that move they would just dot like
they were diving across the windshield
that's what I would do right into the
[ __ ] things mouth you know and as
it's chopping down I drop all right
there you go there's a half hour there's
a half hour you're never gonna get back
okay and you got no one to blame but
yourself and these [ __ ] that are
[ __ ] running around with no mass
trying to show how [ __ ] you know but
what do you want when you're orange
headed stupid leader who hides in a
[ __ ] basement is walking around going
I've never even had a common cold you
know I think when at the end of the day
what's gonna come down is a lot of great
people in in the public eye who slowly
just go nuts they find out that they
have undiagnosed syphilis or some [ __ ]
so I'm thinking maybe the guy back in
the day you know we went to somebody's
[ __ ] party or we're on their boat I
don't know what he did some [ __ ] rich
guy finding himself you know maybe he's
the guy who had that bad soup you ever
think about that because he survived you
know and maybe he's affecting us he
listen what's happening I'm slowly going
[ __ ] nuts here all right that's the
podcast everybody thank you so much all
right
the ridiculousness is over here the
stupidity of what I've said is over okay
you can relax
this is from the bottom of my heart I
really want to thank you guys for
downloading the movie
I know 20 bucks ain't cheap but you know
you bring enough people over there
without your masks on to show everybody
how strong you are you can end up paying
a dollar each you know depending on how
big your living room is okay and
everybody who watched efforts for family
I really appreciate it I am done and now
my next move is I'm gonna watch that new
Spike Lee movie
cuz I heard it's [ __ ] incredible so
that's that's on my my little list here
tonight
alright that's it I hope all you guys
are doing well I hope all you guys are
safe I hope a bunch of people that you
don't know or love or that they won't
even report on will go out and I don't
know what they're gonna do but maybe
they just will maybe that UFO will pick
them up and just get him the [ __ ] out of
here well that'd be great there was a
UFO like vacuum clam I think my
describing Jesus coming back in a UFO
kind of way what if Jesus came back and
he just took the idiots this is what
happens when you get quarantine is you
start going into dictator mode and you
just start remoulding the world in you
know that fits with the universe between
your [ __ ] ears that's what I'm doing I
apologize okay I will hope all you guys
are happy and healthy and all of that
[ __ ] have a wonderful weekend and I'm
gonna try to do a troubadour show
benefit we're gonna try to reach out
them maybe do it this weekend or next
week I don't know I want to do something
I got to do something positive I got to
get out of the [ __ ] house get on a
stage alright that's it I'll talk to you
guys soon love you
sorry hey what's going on it's Bill burr
and it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday what is it
June 18th 2010 yeah I know I know I know
it's Tuesday the 19th I know ok what's
the matter you don't know what happened
don't you follow me on Twitter I
apologize for being a day late sort of
you know I apologize that the 8th guy
who really doesn't give a [ __ ] who just
banged your sister oh I didn't know oh
that was your sister dude I didn't see
it for like [ __ ] 6 months she changed
alright no I was doing I was doing a
show in Chicago
Chicago and you know got out late and
everything and I I didn't bring any of
my [ __ ] with me so I was already gonna
do a half-assed one as far as the sound
I was just gonna record it on my iPhone
man and and then I don't know I ended up
[ __ ] going out until like 4:30 in the
morning and then my flight was at 12:00
so you do the math okay I'm sorry I
partied last a Sunday night like you
know like me my friends successfully
robbed a casino you know like in the end
of sexy beast you know when they robbed
it successful and everybody's laughing
you know [ __ ] you know whatever some
sort of old pub or steakhouse cigars the
whole damn thing yes I was having a
great time I'm not gonna lie to you I
completely forgot that I had to do the
podcast completely 100% for God you know
sorry it's not my fault I've been
jet-setting now I had a great weekend I
started off in San Jose I'm not trying
to make you guys jealous in San Jose
California right there you guys ought to
just shut this whole podcast off just
out of pure Envy you know I don't know
if you guys are fans of The Price is
Right but many times during the showcase
showdown one of the with the final gifts
to make one of those Housewives soccer
moms lose their mind is an
all-expense-paid trip to San Jose
California granted it is the first
showcase it's not the second one second
one I think is to Fresno
yeah went to San Jose and it's slowly
getting better
oh say slowly turning it around every
time I come there it's a little less
scary or at least it feels a little less
weird you know and then like Saturday is
the weirdest day when you work San Jose
in San Jose is one of those classic
cities where you know there's all kinds
of people until the end of the work day
and the second the work day ends
around 5:00 everybody just gets the [ __ ]
out of town and then all of a sudden you
can't you can't even get a goddamn
dinner anywhere everything's closed
everybody sucks closing like one of
those old [ __ ] westerns when some bad
ass has come into town and everybody's
pulling down their curtains closed for
business
that's basically what it feels like but
during the day there's people walking
around to beautiful City they got a
little choo-choo train that goes up and
down the driveway you know and this is
just for people who've never been to San
Jose the people that I feel bad for that
are sitting somewhere and a job that
they don't like dreaming of going to San
Jose California little pictures of SJ as
J town or whatever the [ __ ] they call it
all around your little office cubicle
maybe maybe your workstation out in the
warehouse maybe maybe maybe you drive
for a living
you got those up on the dashboard you
know a spider down Saturday is the
weirdest day because nobody comes in
even during the day so you're walking
around this city with skyscrapers and
there's literally nobody there you feel
like you're in the [ __ ] walking dead
it's the only way to describe it but but
down at the improv the shows were packed
out so I want to thank everyone who came
down I worked with Kevin Shay Kevin Shay
if you guys haven't seen him he's
[ __ ] hilarious totally original I
hope you guys realize that by the way I
don't bring any [ __ ] cupcakes on the
road you know some headliners you know
they'll go out and they'll go out with
some some [ __ ] weak person in front
of them just so they look even better
that's not the way I do it all right I
actually bring out somebody's funny look
at me pat myself on the back now you
know what it is I can't stand I can't
stand watch I can't withstand working
with somebody who sucks that's what it
really is it really has nothing to do
with the crowd all right though let's
get to the truth of this there you go it
does I can you know because when they
when somebody sucks and having to listen
to that act five times during the
[ __ ] week I can't even tell you what
the hell it does to you then they always
end up closing
on the same [ __ ] bit and I don't know
and the bits awful and it's killing
because they're I don't know I don't
know doing something I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is some sort of stand up
trick and it makes me hate them so what
I do is I try to bury myself in the
bowels of the club so I don't have to
hear a word of their act but no matter
how much I do that I still have to
listen to the last minute of if they
have final joke because I have to be
ready to go on so that's the real reason
why I do it alright so there you go so
this is the [ __ ] podcast it is a day
late and as always I don't have enough
[ __ ] hours in the day I should just
brought the stupid goddamn mixer on the
road what the [ __ ] I didn't want to do
it cuz it was too heavy [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways hey I flew back from Chicago and
I watched that that John Carter from
Mars movie or whatever the hell it's
called
and he says I'm John Carter from
Virginia like 90 times and it was
actually sci-fi and I know recently on
the Joe Rogan experience I made fun of
all those sci-fi movies you know if
you're stuck on a plane it's not a bad
movie you know you know what kills me is
they always got to do that [ __ ] in those
[ __ ] those sci-fi movies where they
always have to throw in those [ __ ]
awful invented words when somebody's
arguing everybody's speaking English you
know speak in the goddamn King's English
you understand what everybody's saying I
mean if you went back 300 years in this
[ __ ] country you wouldn't know what
half the people were talking about with
all dayy this and ye that and [ __ ]
goeth and come with it's like it'd be
like reading the Bible I can't make
[ __ ] heads of tale tales of it you
know read the Bible it's like am I still
supposed to be going left to right here
or I go left right to left cuz it
doesn't makes they always have those
dumb lines like the gods of off guard
will not have this they go out of the
way to like invent one word what in the
name of marsupial they had one of those
and actually was just walking through my
headphones down then the douche sitting
next to me looked over at me like what
the [ __ ] is your problem
and
I need you guys to come up with a name
for this phenomenon you ever been
standing in a in an airport terminal and
there's some douche talking really loud
on his cell phone of course you have we
all have right this is big dis giant
dude there's a fat black dude from
England so he sounds like he's in you
know lock stock in Smoking Barrels
whatever the [ __ ] it's called and he's a
tub of [ __ ] which is making me laugh
because everybody in Europe acts like
they're [ __ ] smart and in shape you
know he looked like the [ __ ] dude on
you know you know what do you look like
[Music]
you know that show The Cleveland Brown
show you know his son it's exactly what
he looked like he didn't talk like him
but he had the [ __ ] round glasses the
whole goddamn thing that's what the [ __ ]
he looked like and he's talking and he's
[ __ ] he's filles American fat he's
Chicago fat all right but he's European
so he still has to wear those tight
[ __ ] jeans I don't know why I don't
know what it is about Europe and [ __ ]
suffocate in your balls but Europeans
just their genes cannot be [ __ ] tight
they just cannot be [ __ ] tight enough
they have they have to [ __ ] frame
their package that goddamn units look
like [ __ ] Han Solo's face when he
gets frozen in that little piece of
[ __ ] carbon or whatever the [ __ ] it
was anyways
so he's running his stupid Yap yeah mate
going over to Mel bone after they're
gonna go back over the [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ] right just talking talking
talking big stupid Chicago Bear [ __ ]
gut you know you know when you got the
creases on the side you could stick mail
in there he's got those on the side
right offensive linemen fat you know
he's got great footwork though but look
at his [ __ ] belly and he's just
running his goddamn Yap you know so I
walk away from the guy but he's one of
these guys who takes a little stroll
when he walks so he keeps [ __ ]
walking over into my little area right
sound like I you know pill come on just
[ __ ] don't be this don't be [ __ ]
screaming and yelling just [ __ ] relax
and what is the name of this phenomenon
they start loading the [ __ ] plane I
get on the plane here comes that [ __ ]
douche right still talking yeah might
yeah yeah good day mate yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know good day make
some [ __ ] Australia before I get [ __ ]
from [ __ ] people from England you all
sound the same to me right so he comes
walking up the aisle he's still running
his [ __ ] Yap and I'm just going on
Jesus Christ alright only off listen
this guy for another five four three
until he goes by and the [ __ ]
in my room what are the odds you know
what are the [ __ ] odds goddamn
seventy [ __ ] rows not only is he in
my row he's sitting right next to me and
he stays on the phone the whole [ __ ]
time
yeah might yeah no no teddy bears
watching telly is this Stan right all
[ __ ] time why you swearing I'm not
swearing the whole [ __ ] time sit next
to me running his goddamn Yap with his
fat [ __ ] stomach and the crease on
the side and it's the only this is the
only the only props I will give this
guy's is you know he never seen ever
said hello we didn't speak the whole
flight I loved it I loved that he was as
self-involved his I am and the last
thing I wanted to hear I did last thing
I want to do we start talking him
because he already annoyed the [ __ ] out
of me and I know from experience that if
I'm gonna talk to somebody from another
country at some point they're gonna [ __ ]
on the United States that's something
that they like to do while calling us
the ignorant Americans traveling around
the world you know all knees and elbows
those [ __ ] come over here and
it's just you can't talk to him for more
than [ __ ] five minutes before they
say [ __ ] on America I don't [ __ ]
understand it you know I would never do
that the only the only way I would do
that is if I was onstage in another
country just just for the [ __ ]
ridiculousness of it to start making fun
of their [ __ ] country but if I was
sitting on a plane I would just be
totally you have a beautiful country
blah blah blah blah be a decent [ __ ]
guy
I don't Jesus Christ
the hell was I just gonna try just
remembered something in the middle of
that the hell was I talking about hang
on a second let me think about this oh
yeah I remember what it was did I tell
this story like [ __ ] four months ago I
pulled my big-ass truck into this small
spot but there was nobody on the other
side of me and I was fine right
when I came out somebody had pulled in
and it was really tight as far as I con
either side of my truck and then I
didn't have a lot of space to back out
so was this [ __ ] problem I keep trying
to back you know back out come back in
back out like into my way in so this
[ __ ] guy starts helping me out I
think he was from England and he's like
you know next time why don't you do the
unamerican thing and back in and I
[ __ ] I it's like you can't even help
me out of this spot with our [ __ ]
nitpicking you're [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what I'll listen to it from Australia
but England the amount of [ __ ] that is
going on in the world still because of
those [ __ ] the fact that they actually
[ __ ] give you had the balls to give
the United States [ __ ] the very least be
like hey welcome to the party
welcome you guys are slowly catching up
to us historically it's the biggest
[ __ ] oppressive douchebags on the
planet you want to come at me like that
absolutely but if you're gonna [ __ ]
come at me like you didn't do all this
other [ __ ] out there the [ __ ]
caste system in India and all that
[ __ ] crap this [ __ ] that happen to
Rwanda you know that's all I got two
examples I don't know anything else the
Falkland Islands Jesus the ignorant
American strikes again but you know what
I'm saying if I actually read I could
[ __ ] bury you guys in this argument
all right with your Jolly Rancher flag
whatever the [ __ ] you call it all right
thank God I don't have a gig coming up
in English after that little thing you
know oh Jesus I got our old G I got a
ton of [ __ ] for my [ __ ] comments
about about hair metal last week you
know up dude I wasn't saying it was all
bad come on this is what I should okay
look
disco music wasn't all bad okay look
freak come on you really think that's a
bad [ __ ] song you do oh really and
what in every rose has its thorn is
better you want to go back and forth
little tit-for-tat here [ __ ] the
Freak blows any of those heavy metal
ballads away all right
I'm not saying van Halen with David Lee
Roth was to [ __ ] all right it's kind of
like the Red Sox with Theo Epstein and
Tito and all that now that they blew it
up we're gonna be [ __ ] who else who
else was great in the a there was a lot
of good [ __ ] [ __ ] but there was just
you know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
give me an R Oh Oh C CK and what do you
got rock and what are you gonna do rock
you really can you come up with a disco
song worse than that that's your
challenge for this weekend if you can I
will shut the [ __ ] up about this because
I'm not saying it was all bad I'm not
saying I didn't like Iron Maiden
I didn't say that I didn't say that I
didn't like Metallica which I actually
didn't in the 80s I thought that it was
too hard was too hard for me okay I had
to stay in my borderline hair metal a
little bit of glam and oh he's wearing
jeans on stage he's bringing it back
little [ __ ] music box that I was in I
missed out on a lot of good [ __ ] all
that new wave [ __ ] some of that stuff
was good some of the talking head stuff
early on that was stuff was all good I
missed out on all of that you know I
liked their mainstream [ __ ]
burn it down a house that's all I listen
to um let me see here if I can get oh
where the hell is it let me see if I can
get any any comments that people telling
me all these people giving me [ __ ] for
my podcast being late the [ __ ] dude
hurry up with my free entertainment
somebody do a picture of a big dick
that's nice
stop jerking off and give us the [ __ ]
podcast for [ __ ] sakes by the way happy
birthday see what I do this is my crowd
this is what I facilitate oh Jesus
Christ I can't find it anymore look for
all you [ __ ] metalheads out there
alright I wasn't saying you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about okay you
can't tell me that you don't watch some
of those old videos in it and then
they're not [ __ ] I'm not gay I'm not
you know what I'm not letting you suck
me back into this argument again
all right I said what I had to say okay
it's a lot of Motley Crue's [ __ ] I did
like some of this [ __ ] didn't hold up so
much do when that theater of paint or
when they will go [ __ ] coming on
stage looking like they sold Mary Kay
Cosmetics I mean come on
I get in his [ __ ] drum set when
[ __ ] all the way around but come on
you can't tell me that even they don't
look at it you know what look at the
[ __ ] cover of theater pain okay I
want you to hold that up and then think
about my argument and then still tell me
to go [ __ ] myself alright and if you can
pull that off I will all right I will
[ __ ] off alright so anyways you're
listening to the Monday morning podcast
everybody I do one of these every single
week if you're new to the the podcast is
what I do I [ __ ] on things then people
[ __ ] back on me and then maybe in the
end of it we we learned something we
have learned [ __ ] on this podcast Adam
we we've learned that that sitting in a
cubicle is not something that you
dreamed of as a child and that you
eventually want to get out of it we've
learned that I can't be funny without
saying [ __ ] and [ __ ] every other word
you guys what else you know that I'm
going to hell
or I'm going into the ground one of the
other depending on whether you're
religious or not you've also learned
that there's no reason to go to the post
office hey listen if you see if you're
still going to the post office you're
probably still listening to Fiat er of
pain on cassette tape
[Laughter]
what stamps.com you ask are you new to
my podcast and you haven't heard this
commercial 40,000 times this is what
stamps calm and stamps calm is this
wonderful website that eliminates you
ever having to go to the post office
again okay think about all the things
that happen when you go to the post
office the homeless guy holding the door
like you can't open it yourself
okay and maybe you're a liberal and you
want to give him some you're gonna give
him some money okay but you know damn
well you're not gonna touch his hand so
you gotta do that little throw you got
to do a little throw you know what I do
is I always try to throw it right at
their [ __ ] breastplate right their
chest and that way they can kind of do
like a basket catch that's what I do you
know because I've tried to do the
dropping thing the hand is so callous it
just [ __ ] it bounces right off of it
it's like you threw it against the
[ __ ] concrete and it falls on the
ground and then they're crawling around
trying to [ __ ] pick up a quarter and
you feel bad you know I'm gonna tell you
about that time I gave that homeless guy
some change as I was walking out of
stand up New York on the Upper West Side
in New York City I gave him some change
and as I was walking away I just heard
[ __ ] yeah I heard the sound of my change
being thrown for the [ __ ] sidewalk it
was an angry drunk you know when he had
his standard it's like give me some cash
or go [ __ ] yourself and I'm off but did
I get mad I think I laughed my ass off
no I think I got mad cuz I was by myself
so then it just kind of was him against
me so I got upset but if I was with
somebody else I would have had to laugh
cuz they would have been laughing at me
anyway stamps calm everybody if you
still go to the post office to send out
letters and packages the truth is you're
wasting your time okay and take my
advice okay you stamp calm instead
alright I send out all my DVDs this way
send them out to the clubs I got my
little scale I put on my little mr.
McFee feely
speedy delivery hat crank the whole damn
thing out slap the stamp on it and I'm
done never have to go to the post office
stamp calm is quick and easy way to get
postage how does it work bill I'll tell
you you can buy in print official US
postage using what you already have your
own computer and printer they also give
you the little digital scale my favorite
thing you know I feel a little
kindergartner playing post office except
it's real man they give you a little
digital scale scale stamps calm
eliminates guesswork you'll get the
exact postage for any letter or package
24/7 whenever you need it and the
mailman comes and picks it all up you
know unless you live in the city all
right what if you live in the city
that'll be a letter bill can you please
not bring up problems with the product
you'll never have to go to the post
office again endorsement I'm so stupid
talk about your use of stamps calm I
already did that so anyways here we go I
got a special offer right now if you use
my name burr be you are are for this
special offer you get a no risk trial
plus a hundred and ten dollar bonus
offer it includes the digital scale and
up to fifty five dollars in free postage
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything on the radio microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Furby you are that stamps calm enter BRR
and welcome to the wonderful world of
never having to go to the post office
again there you go see what I just did
it's like you would Dayton some psycho
chick and I just broke up with her for
you you don't have to ever deal with her
again now you can go find the love of
your life you'll have time to do things
like that maybe get back into p90x thing
you know maybe you could do that because
you're not standing in line at the post
office there's all kinds of stuff you
could do you could sit around and get
fat if you wanted to mmm
you know I really like I just like
printing stamps after the post office is
closed that's what I enjoy that's my big
thing I know I know it's just a little
thing in life it's just something that
makes me smile anyways what else what do
we got so Jesus bill you gonna be a day
late and you have nothing to [ __ ] and
talk about okay here we go here's some
more hair metal stuff new rush album and
God knows rush
the king of hair metal you know a lot of
Rush fans won't they won't admit to that
but they had that awful period where
they drew just teasin up their hair
remember that and had all the eyeliner
and those monsters they brought out on
stage was [ __ ] horrible dude they
never [ __ ] did yet man all right bill
you're always saying how Neil Peart is
to mechanical of a drummer for your
taste I'm always saying he's a beast but
I just like I don't hear any I don't
know I just it it doesn't get me all
right so anyway I got a lot of balls
making fun of the guy you know I can
play more with one hand than I could
with all four limbs and falling down a
flight of stairs anyways on the new
album the producer acting like a
conductor during the recordings to help
drive live emotion into his playing the
drum parts were not as planned the album
is really good and the guitar solos are
amazing go [ __ ] yourself okay ii-i'll
give it a shot you know I'm just not I
was I was never into I just never was
into the pen today's Tom Sawyer's the
mean mean guy ding ding ding boo boo BAM
I don't know I just never got into that
[ __ ] Plus every time I would almost get
into this [ __ ] like just something else
they would do that what would annoy me I
was watching I was reading some sports
article one time and they interviewed
Getty Getty Lee and evidently he's a
bluejay fan and they were playing the
Red Sox and he made fun of Red Sox fans
and I was just that was just a further
[ __ ] this guy I don't know dude III like
Bonham better I like guys like Steve
Jordan
they don't play nearly as much but a lot
of those guys there's very few of those
guys I gotta have those giant [ __ ]
drum sets that are that really blow me
away I actually you know who I like is
uh Simon Phillips he sat in with the WHO
on that tour I went to in 1989 you know
thinking I was seeing the WHO and then
years later [ __ ] Pete Townsend goes
when they had a new tour oh yeah that
that
stole mate that wasn't the who that that
was the who ah nice that always pissed
me off it's like really we didn't say
that when I was buying the [ __ ]
tickets you [ __ ] why don't you go do
some more research on child pornography
oh Jesus bill but he's [ __ ] was
unreal on that and I don't know I just
recently just came across one of his
solos and it's not something if you're a
younger drummer you're going to enjoy
because you're gonna find the beginnings
boring as he builds his way up to it but
it's uh I don't know has a beginning
middle and an end to the solo which is
right think really [ __ ] hard to do
one drums and like I said a lot of those
guys were they got who said it was that
other guy played with like Dream Theater
a lot of guys go nuts about him and
Thomas Lang like those guys are
incredible [ __ ] players but after a
while I just it's just everything's
played at like 90 million miles an hour
and it gets [ __ ] it all starts to
sound the same that's the thing about
speed after a while it all [ __ ]
sounds to say which is the genius of an
eddie van halen to me cuz eddie van
halen could play that fast yet still
could give me the chills cuz he still
had some sort of feeling and soul
underneath it and by the time the 80s
came around everybody learned to do is
tap on [ __ ] and then it just became who
can play it the fastest and it was like
an auctioneer playing a guitar after a
while and I just I never [ __ ] the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] 20 minutes wasn't
every solo in the [ __ ] 80s every
concert you went to they'd be like then
they'd [ __ ] slow it down if it beta
it big it big and then they look at the
crowd the crowd be like he's basically
doing the same lick over and over and
over again he was just speeding it up
and slowing it down and I think half the
drum solos with the same thing they'd
slow it all the way down to just like
you know hits on the snare drum did ya
and then you'd stand up put your fist in
the air and everyone would go nuts and
then you would sit down and you would
just slowly speed it up again and then
somebody would come out skipping around
and [ __ ] kick their foot in the air
and then again they go back into the
sock right oh and the women dressed like
[ __ ]
it was such a great [ __ ] time it
really was and I got a you know I really
never thought that I would see girls
dress more skanky than they did back
then you know with the [ __ ] ripped up
pantyhose fishnets [ __ ] it was just it
was phenomenal with the Flashdance
influence so the [ __ ] thing was
always falling off their shoulder half a
titty hanging out it was just it was
phenomenal
and uh I don't know
going out and [ __ ] San Jose like the
Saint these girls I swear to go with the
[ __ ] hooker shoes it's phenomenal but
uh doing one thing about San Jose on
Friday and Saturday nights there is
enough police presence there it's like
they're anticipating a [ __ ] riot it's
unreal there's like they they have
everything short of like the helmets and
the shields like I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened every time I start
thinking like I a San Jose is not a bad
[ __ ] place you come out there on a
Friday or Saturday night and there's
like there's like 40 cops on every block
it seems not in case something happens
it's some vibe is more when something
happens and you just feel like the later
you're out he just like oh this is
really [ __ ] stupid I need to go back
in I need to jump on that little
electric train that only goes six blocks
and get back to my hotel hey by the way
they had something out there called
Juneteenth that I never heard of can
somebody please explain to me somebody
of african-american heritage what
exactly that is somebody said that's
when slaves were freed Juneteenth why is
it Juneteenth why isn't it like one
specific day or did they [ __ ] drag it
out between June 13th and June 19th you
know is one last little [ __ ] you like
alright we're going to free some time in
the Teague's
hey mr. white man it's [ __ ]
June 13th what do you say can I go now
well maybe tomorrow just trying to get
another four or five days out he is that
what happened I don't [ __ ] know
alright fantasy beer league hey Bill
you're starting a beer league hockey
team and you can pick any NHL our past
or present the NHL hockey player
wouldn't necessarily be in the prime of
his career but something close who do
you pick
I think the inclination is to take
someone like Mario Lemieux but I think
that'd get boring as [ __ ] after a while
yeah you probably [ __ ] get mad when I
yanked on his jersey and threatened to
retire because I think I'd go with
someone like Rick talk it he can still
dominate your league and you can imagine
drinking beers with them afterwards
exactly you answered your own question
that's exactly who I would get I get
[ __ ] who's that guy Jesus I'm so bad
with the names the second the season
ends I can't remember anybody's name
who's the [ __ ] guy he's on the
Rangers and said that everybody gets my
sloppy seconds somebody like him
somebody who can play and is funny you
know I you know something what about
cars sell oh I always thought Cursillo
could actually play that guy can
actually play the game can score goals
and he can beat the [ __ ] out of people
which he did so you know he's got great
[ __ ] stories and he looks like he
drinks so I would definitely pick
somebody like that the last thing I
would do was get like a Sidney Crosby
you know he just doesn't seem like he
never passed the puck and you know when
I accidentally tripped him if I ever got
anywhere near him because God knows I'd
be there good trying to get the puck I
would accidentally trip him and you know
if he didn't get the call or even he got
the call he just get up and would do
that [ __ ] where he was shaking his head
but not looking at me with his [ __ ]
rosy lips yeah I think I could maybe I
go old school you know Rick Middleton
was always a favorite of mine nifty
maybe him maybe Jay Miller some old
school tough guys Bob Probert God rested
so if he was still around I get guys
like that maybe some goons or something
like that all right but I need some
advice bill going for it going for it oh
Jesus here we go going for it this is
some guy in from the 80s he's gonna go
for it I was one of the worst [ __ ]
expressions ever in the 80s to remember
that and it bottomed out in that Rocky
movie in Rocky three or maybe that
started at all when clubber Lang got in
his face is like a [ __ ] look and then
Rocky's like go for it and that was
supposed to be like this big moment like
he's not scared anymore
go for it that everybody in that part of
the 80s everybody in the early to mid
8th and promote like the early 80s and
all those [ __ ] movies everybody
dressed like they were on their way to
an aerobics class in fact I think such
stresses Stallone didn't he have on leg
warmers during part of his workouts in
those movies I can't remember dear bill
dear bill since I was 12 years old I've
been playing blues music professionally
around the Colorado and Front Range area
what the [ __ ] is the Front Range area is
that Wyoming bomba de de bomba de de
I've made good money
what kind of gigs did you get in the
Front Range area um every year I play
blues music on Hitler's birthday for
this Aryan group slash meth lab in
[ __ ] Casper Wyoming I've made good
money and lots of friends on the way
this year I even made it to the finals
at the International Blues Challenge
needless to say I've been blessed so far
in life yeah and you must be a [ __ ]
beast if you can do that he says not bad
for a 16 year old go [ __ ] yourself you
know that's awesome for a 16 year old
Jesus Christ I wasn't doing [ __ ] I was
doing was flunking every class in high
school and I had my driver's life I've
got my driver's license the second I
turned 16
the second I was eligible and I took it
on a
I actually took my head the balls to
take it with a stick-shift who's a 78
Chevette for speed and the only reason
why I say I had the balls every car in
my family we always had stick shifts I
don't know why you know was funny we had
we had manual transmission but there
wasn't a sports car to be found anyways
here's my problem ever since I was eight
years old and saw Reservoir Dogs I
wanted to write in direct movies now
this isn't a choice between my two two
passions I do plan on doing both for the
rest of my life but with the screenplay
competition I have little hope for why
do you have a little hoping a screenplay
competition they have [ __ ] like that
don't they
what are you saying you're not good good
good at it I don't know bill why don't
you read the rest of it you'll figure it
out a screenplay competition I have
little hope for oh I see no those do
exist dude I don't know where they are
but they do exist I remember Matt Damon
and Ben Affleck had that project
greenlight they're there there's always
people doing stuff like I can't say
always but there is [ __ ] like that
anyways a dad that's recovering from a
car accident sorry to hear that
and a mom working to keep our family in
a home I have no idea how to start
making my first feature film now you're
probably thinking you're 16 no I'm not
I'm thinking you're ahead of the game
this is good
but I have no money for the high school
I go to anymore and being in the Blues
world for so long I know that tomorrow I
will wake up and be 43 wondering if I
accomplished everything I wanted to
being a 16 year old blue blues musician
whose most likely isn't going to get a
high school diploma and wants to make
movies Jesus Christ dude first thing
I'll tell you is you got it you got a
[ __ ] you got to put a little sunshine
in your thoughts there there youngster
I'll stop listen to that [ __ ] blues
music making you just depressed once you
listen to a little hair metal it's happy
anyways I'm pretty lost it's scary
because I'm at the place where the
things you do now affect your future any
advice on how to
keep positive as I try and become a
filmmaker would be greatly appreciated
thanks and sorry for writing so [ __ ]
much yeah dude you first of all you're
acting like you're 86 and not 16 alright
you're 16 you're way ahead of the
[ __ ] game alright when I was 14 I was
gonna go to Notre Dame and become a
lawyer by the time I was 16 I was
thinking well maybe I'll learn a trade
alright that's how quickly I [ __ ] you
know went off the rails now as a bunch
of people in trades so what I'm a [ __ ]
if I can't know you're a [ __ ] genius
because you can make a lip or ever the
follower the [ __ ] that went this is how
you know you learn to make movies dude
you just go ahead and you [ __ ] make
one all right this is the deal you don't
have any [ __ ] money alright so you
could make enough money like just
playing music with a goddamn bucket in
front of you in downtown Denver save up
and get an iPhone if you don't already
have one all right you got an iphone you
can [ __ ] shoot some video then upload
it on and just you know do it for
nothing upload it on the computer or a
friend's computer whoever you making the
movie with you just that's the way to
learn how to do [ __ ] that's the advice
I'll give you just go out and you do
[ __ ] and and every time you think a
negative thought that saying I can't do
this you have to [ __ ] mentally beat
the [ __ ] out of that thought and you
have to really become conscious too of
as to what your brain is telling you you
know because you seem like you're in
your very early on so I don't think it's
gonna be that deep of a groove but your
brain is like catastrophizing okay
everything you're thinking of doing
somehow it ends with you slamming into a
brick wall alright and if you think that
way you become paralyzed and you can't
you can't step forward but you really
your heart wants to step forward but you
can't because your brain keeps [ __ ]
showing you that brick wall
so what's then gonna happen is your
[ __ ] heart is gonna be waking you up
in the middle of the night
thinking thoughts like what the [ __ ] you
doing what the [ __ ] are you doing and
then you then you know you you're gonna
start drinking and it's gonna be or
whatever the [ __ ] something bad it's not
gonna be good it's not gonna be good
then you'll become miserable and then
you can see somebody young one day who
isn't in their way and you're actually
gonna try to discourage them which is
gonna make you feel like a piece of [ __ ]
so the biggest thing I would work on is
you just have to really you have to be
conscious of when your brains telling
you you can't do something you're 16
[ __ ] years old okay you got the whole
your whole world the whole [ __ ] life
in front of you and you know you can
start making a movie tomorrow and this
is the great thing dude you have just
give yourself the permission to suck
it's your first one it's supposed to
suck all right I had no idea to do
stand-up I just signed up for an open
mic and I went on [ __ ] stage and I
hung on for dear life and you know what
I sucked and I sucked for a while but
every time I sucked a little bit less
and that's how you got to do it and I
had all that negative [ __ ] going on in
my head and I bought those [ __ ] books
on how to think positive which was
hilarious with my negative mind as just
as I'm reading it wanting to absorb it
I'm also ripping it apart saying this is
[ __ ] but I don't know unless you're
like clinically depressed just negative
thought is just a habit you can get out
of that's kind of what I found and you
just have to be conscious of it and you
know it's really just a choice you know
you just think a negative thought you're
like alright there's a negative thought
step back look at it be like oh do I
want to [ __ ] you know tie myself to
that thing and have it pull me all the
way down to the ground or am I gonna say
you know what [ __ ] that thought in in
think something positive no I'm gonna
make I'm gonna I'm gonna make a movie
what I would do if I was you without
which I would just be thinking about
guys like Tarantino or Spike Lee or
Kevin Smith any of these guys who just
were like [ __ ] it I'm gonna make a movie
and they just went out and did it the
next thing you know that they they had a
career those guys can do it you could do
it that's just focus on them
you know that's what I do [ __ ] it you
know I'm a balding redhead in this
[ __ ] business who has a nerve to try
to go an audition for movies every week
where the [ __ ] do I get off doing that
who wants to see that on screen you know
but what do I think of people still want
to see Ed Harris they don't care so
[ __ ] I'm gonna look at Ed Harris I'm
not gonna [ __ ] be focusing on all
these washboard middles
full head of [ __ ] hair run for
president looking [ __ ] jaws like I
kill myself Jesus Christ now I'm
starting to depress me
that's what I would do you want to make
a movie you go [ __ ] make a movie
that's what you that's what I would do I
don't know why you feel like you're not
gonna finish high school you could do
that you know you can do it you know
there's gotta be a way that you can get
a high school diploma what if you have
to transfer you got to [ __ ] transfer
to a new school that's cheaper so what
you come in all of a sudden you're the
new guy hey who the [ __ ] is this guy
right you come in like [ __ ] Clint
Eastwood all of a sudden you're getting
blown by some chick because she thinks
you're mysterious because you have a
different area code it can happen just
you know I was gonna say buy a trench
coat but that's probably not good to do
in Colorado is it oh that was a bad one
sorry you know what I mean just you
gotta think positive
all right you keep thinking negative
that shit's gonna happen if you think
positive and you do the work that's the
critical part you'll be fine and thus
ends my little self-help after-school
special here all right now I don't write
Tim don't don't keep taking that [ __ ] I
want to hear a few from you in six
months going hey I actually made the
movie didn't come out that bad you're
gonna learn a bunch of [ __ ] you know
believe me and that's the kind of thing
also that never ends I'm still learning
[ __ ] every time I go and tape a special
there's always something ah [ __ ] you
know the first time when I did why do I
do this it was the first time I was ever
the guy calling the shots and I forgot
to tell them that I needed a clock I
just assumed that it was gonna be there
and I went out and there was no clock
there was no way to tell how long I
didn't know what time I went out and I
ended up being a little bit of a
[ __ ] at the end of it so then the
next time I did a special
I had a [ __ ] clock you know and you
know I I just did another special I
learned something on that and I was like
what the [ __ ] what am I gonna have this
thing down there's always gonna be
obstacles it's just it's just basically
how it is all right so there we go
now how about what do you say if I can
find it a little bit of advertising at
this point gamefly.com everybody do you
like playing video games well good I
have a great website for you
gamefly.com right now you can try the
new Max Payne 3
Ghost Recon or the Special Ops game that
sounds like one that I would like I love
those games we get this go around just
killing people for as long as you want
for the fraction of the cost of the game
game flight comm offers over 8,000 video
games for PlayStation Xbox Wii and now
your PC do you realize how insane that
is
youngsters please don't take that for
granted do you know like back in the day
when I was a kid if you had an Atari and
you had like 12 games like people were
jealous of you
8,000 video games for PlayStation Xbox
Wii and now your PC for my listeners
only you get free 15 days to disc offer
just give it a try and if you like it
you know after 15 days if you like you
to keep it if you don't you can cancel
it it's free everybody 315 days 8000
games for free so my whiskey' voice here
you know you can't beat that either you
want it you don't are they doing that
down the car dealership hey take this
Corvette out for 15 days the end of 15
days if you want to buy it you can if
not just bring it back but until then
it's free including the guests they
would never do that that would be insane
well they're doing it at gamefly.com so
go to billboard.com the podcast page you
click on the game fly banner or go to
WWE my comm slash / for my for a special
for special my listeners what come on
people I can't read for the love of God
at least write it correctly
gamefly.com slash / bur for a special my
listeners only free 15 day to disc trial
yeah that wasn't me that was them all
right you did you guys understand that
by the end of it I was doing so well
with that copy - you know all right
let's get the last one out of the way so
I can just be like a [ __ ] for the rest
of this I amazon.com everybody all right
do you go there do you buy stuff well if
you think it going there rather than
going directly to amazon.com once again
go to the podcast page on Billboard comp
and click on the amazon banner and just
you know buy whatever the hell you want
not saying you got to buy anything but
uh if you want to buy something if you
go through my website to do it they're
gonna kick me back a little bit of that
money and 10% of that goes to help to
the Wounded Warriors Project so you'll
be supporting my podcast and supporting
the troops and it doesn't cost you any
extra money on amazon.com all it does is
wear out your index joint just a little
bit more by having to click two more
times that's all it does so maybe
someday when you're 90 and you go to
point at some kid and your finger locks
you can blame me okay but until then
you'll be you'll be you'll be helping
out my podcast and more importantly
you'll be supporting the troops and I
gotta tell you it's awesome it's all
it's been a great thing you know I mean
I've been able to send out a checks to
the Wounded Warriors Project which makes
me feel great it's just a great cause
and I've been doing they're just been
rounding up to the nearest hundred
anyways and I'm actually thinking about
giving you know even more than that oh
come on how do you how do you beat that
project you know all right that's it all
right let's move on here advice don't
take [ __ ] from anybody
question mark bill sometimes you and
your podcast with go [ __ ] yourselves and
don't take [ __ ] from anyone well let me
tell you my story back in November a cop
pulled me over roughed me up was a huge
[ __ ] and wrote up every rinky-dink
e-ticket he could not okay now wait a
minute what happened you were just
driving down the street and this guy
just pulled you over
I need a little bit of the backstory
here was this guy did you know did he
get into a big fight with his wife and
then took it out on you or we did you
say something wise to the guy and he
said all right I'm not in the [ __ ]
mood
anyways let's see if we can figure it
out here at the end of the altercation I
shook his hand look him straight in the
eyes and gave him that look that says I
will see you in court [ __ ] I showed
up in court this Monday to defend myself
my plan was to stand before that [ __ ]
and have him explain his actions to me
in a court of law
hey I dude this ain't gonna work out
unless she had a witness I wanted to ask
him even then that doesn't work out I
wanted to ask him if twisting my arms so
much that I couldn't use it for a few
days was justified I want to ask him why
he decided that me 5/6 175 pounds was a
threat to him 6 foot to 6 foot 3 250
that he need to hit me from behind dude
call me an [ __ ] but I'm not a hundred
percent buying this story because you
didn't say what happened before this
this guy just did this is this guy like
the [ __ ] worst cop ever I don't know
here we go I wanted to I wanted to know
why he needed to demean me while I was
handcuffed in the back of the paddy
wagon I then wanted to ask him how many
excessive force complaints he had
against him the answer is 4
oh [ __ ] so I'm wrong here I wanted to
ask him how his marriage ended his
ex-wife has a restraining order against
him for domestic violence all right I
tap out you're right you're right sorry
I wanted to ask him what part of protect
and serve did he not understand I wanted
to end the questioning with him
explaining how he got caught on a cell
phone camera assaulting a motorist you
can look up the video on YouTube under
Milwaukee Police Lambo driver L AM Bo
driver here's what sucks in Milwaukee if
the cop that wrote you the ticket this
doesn't show up in court your case is
dismissed
and you don't have to pay anything well
guess guess why I told you that the
piece of [ __ ] didn't show up in court
ah that's awful I need advice do I let
this all be water under the bridge
do I take this [ __ ] down I really want
justice but I don't want to be beaten by
other cops what should I do
[Music]
well I think you just shed some light
Milwaukee police Lambo driver all my
listeners will probably look up and
watch that now this guy sounds like a
dangerous guy look you know this is what
I would do if I was gonna try to take
this dude down what I would do is you
know what the local news loves doing now
they love showing like YouTube videos
and they love talking about Twitter and
all that type of stuff because they're
desperately trying to get the kids and
people because they're losing all this
viewership to to the Internet so the
fact that you you have this
controversial thing you have this [ __ ]
up law and you have a youtube video of
this guy that makes that's like one of
those perfect little pieces you know
coming up next Milwaukee police officer
a little out of line check out the
YouTube video that everybody's been
talking about earlier you mean you can
go that way but yeah I mean you're
taking a you're definitely gonna take a
[ __ ] risk you know taking the Rodney
King died this week and that brought up
that whole video and all that type of
[ __ ] and I know you know the guy just
pulled over that's what you're supposed
to do I know I mean look who's kidding
Oh Ronnie King was gonna get beat down
no matter what I mean if you've run from
the [ __ ] cops I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are you got to get beat down but if
you get back up you charge them a couple
of times
abso-fucking-lutely but you know there's
got to be a way to take a guy down
without giving them 12 [ __ ] skull
fractures you know what I'm saying it's
a fight oh no it's a it's it's it's it's
a [ __ ] thankless job and then it's a
really dangerous job if the wrong kind
of person gets uh gets the job why did
my phone just go off that's right I can
I do that [ __ ] so I don't personally I
can't I can't ever watch that Rodney
King thing again that's like
it's the most brutal thing ever and
actually when you watch that now you go
thank God they got [ __ ] what do you
call those things
taser what clea what do you call those
things what do they call those things
that you they just uh they zap you do
you guys ever see that one that one were
they the cop what the [ __ ] do you call
those things he got tased he got [ __ ]
is a Taser Clio why am I so dumb huh
[ __ ] love this dog you know that Clio
underrated having a dog it's the best
[ __ ] thing ever anyway since this I
got I got to get you this YouTube video
now that I brought it up it's uh it's
basically they're doing a demonstration
of one of those [ __ ] things whatever
the [ __ ] you call him that I just can't
think that why do I keep saying it's a
Taser I know it's not a is it a Taser he
got tased and I can't [ __ ] it
my brain is mush so anyways there's one
cop gonna zap another cop to demonstrate
it to the class and look man I don't
give a [ __ ] how much of a man you are
you get [ __ ] zapped with electricity
you're gonna make a noise most guys go
like and they [ __ ] go down a this guy
[ __ ] shoots it at the guy and this
dude sounds like he's like ending an
opera
he gets tased he's like just [ __ ]
drop just literally something like that
and drops and I just love how the cop
who shoots him tries to act like he just
didn't scream out like a little [ __ ]
girl man it's hilarious
but but getting back that yeah dude
that's that's a serious um that's a
serious thing and you you know if this
guy really is as bad as you're saying
you know the right thing is not to let
it go the right thing is to try and shed
some light on it and hopefully that they
can get this guy off the force because
he's given decent cops a bad name there
you go so but your your worries are
definitely you know valid I mean
considering none of those cops during
the Rodney King none of them got [ __ ]
they got they got off you can get off
doing that I mean Jesus Christ you know
that dude who shot that kid on that
platform and in Oakland that was [ __ ]
brutal he's like oh I thought it was my
I thought it was my house keys I didn't
realize it was my gun and he [ __ ] got
away with that
I'm not trashing cops I'm just saying
I'm not saying they're all [ __ ] bad
but I'm just saying it's it's a it's
practically [ __ ] impossible it
literally even if you have video I think
you have to have the combination of
having video and then you have to be you
have to be a certain level of wealth and
influence because if you're broke you
know I don't think that there that you
know you there's no way they're just
gonna be like yeah go [ __ ] yourself
you're done you know and then when you
add racism into it I mean you're pretty
much pretty much game set match which is
[ __ ] unfortunate so I'm talking about
society way beyond my [ __ ] intellect
so I'm gonna tap out here already trash
[ __ ] hair medal and I'm gonna have
[ __ ] angry psycho cops mad at me and
then other people [ __ ] think I don't
know what the [ __ ] okay response to
having kids
my kid is turning me into a queer okay
hey bill I listen to the latest podcast
like I always do
I heard that you I heard you start to
make a crack about having kids then
catch yourself and and say I hear it
here it's the greatest thing ever though
I'm a total hard-ass attitude attitude
wise at least not a tough guy bully
piece of [ __ ] alright so you're a ball
you're a ball breaking wiseass like me
so anyways I'll make this short so you
can read something more interesting
i crack [ __ ] jokes listen to rock music
and watch sports non-stop but my newborn
son is queering me up if he gives me one
more cute look
giggle it'll probably start a path to a
wardrobe of visors khaki shorts braided
leather belts and penny loafers with no
socks I bet in a few years I'll probably
raise the pitch of my voice and at the
end of every at the end of every
question I ask him well that's good that
gives me hope you sound like an angry
walled-off emotional psycho and this
kids making you giggle honestly sir when
was the last time you giggled you know
that's when you know you had a fucked-up
childhood is he actually legitimately
giggle and then it makes you hate
yourself and then you actually even when
you're by yourself if you giggled you
actually get embarrassed you literally
to the point your face gets a little
flush like that's how much shame you
carry for actually having any sort of
opinion on any sort of a motion that
isn't just straight up go [ __ ] yourself
well that's good man I'm happy for you
I hope I hope that happens to me someday
I hope I'm I'm uh you know I don't know
mature enough at some point to ever have
a kid dilemma bill what would you choose
to either have sex with any woman in the
world
neiha wouldn't mind I wouldn't care if
she gave a [ __ ] if I my choice of any
[ __ ] woman in the world just to do it
one time that wouldn't be worth it it
wouldn't be worth it to lose me abut it
but my dick would override that wisdom
in the moment or to have access to the
truth about any government secret in
history what would you do all right well
how would I know any government secret
in history would they know that I knew
it and then they'd start tracking me
down and then I'd have to be like
[ __ ] Jason Bourne for the rest of my
life never getting to sleep more than
five seconds between concussions all
right first of all if I could have sex
with any woman in the world who would it
be
let's see here well you got you Kate you
got you got your major groups
I think you have four major groups you
have famous you have celebrity women you
have like celebrities like movie stars
then you have you have rock star chicks
sports chicks and then he got chicks
from your past you know some teacher you
always wanted to bang any woman in the
world you're gonna go back but she has
to be as hot as she was oh this is a
dilemma oh by the way the other day I
was at a comedy club in that that pink
was down was actually in the crowd and I
didn't go up or any by she walked by it
was [ __ ] absolutely like slump
against the wall beautiful absolutely
[ __ ] gorgeous I'm telling you
something like those [ __ ] like super
famous people like they don't even look
real when they walk by you they just
liked it that genetics like I don't know
what happened but I'm just like jesus
[ __ ] christ you know I mean I knew
she was good-looking right I've seen the
videos but everybody looks good in
videos you know and then half the time
you see him in [ __ ] real life I'll
tell you this right now if you ever see
pink she does not disappoint [ __ ]
just write down the checklist absolutely
[ __ ] gorgeous you know beautiful
[ __ ] dress that was sexy but not
[ __ ]
she had the [ __ ] tattoos but not too
many of them [ __ ] just absolutely
[ __ ] gorgeous I felt like I was in
second grade you know like when a
beautiful girl walks by you like a boob
do you don't even know what to say all
right so let's get back to it so if I
could bang any woman in the [ __ ]
world
well there's two kinds of women there's
the woman that you [ __ ] is absolutely
gorgeous and makes you believe in an
afterlife and then there's the other
girl you want to bang just a shutter the
[ __ ] up
[Laughter]
you know what I mean like I bet there's
a lot of liberals out there that want to
just bang and culture just stick their
dick right in her [ __ ] mouth you know
what I mean
but not like a totally malicious way
just really put one on her where she's
just [ __ ] losing it and you know
making noises in bed that she didn't
know she could make and you know and
make her be able to make those noises
even though she knows that you voted for
Obama you know there's that kind of
[ __ ] right and then there's the other
one where you just want to [ __ ] you
know run down the beach hand-in-hand
with some girl at least in my world
that's the only those are the only two
what would I do you know what I would
choose I would choose sex with any woman
in the world because that government
learning a government secret I've
actually done that on a certain level
and it just it's like being in show
business is when you're like wouldn't it
be cool to meet this person and then you
meet them and they're like the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ] ever or they I don't
know they're just like they just do
something that just it just blows your
whole [ __ ] image it's it's it's the
Wizard of Oz thing well you know what
you don't want to peek around the corner
you know what you don't want to peek
around the corner so what what I would
do is I would definitely I would I would
I would I would have sex with some and
and you know what I would have to be
somebody famous and then out of respect
for Nia I would have to be just to shut
him the [ __ ] up kind of woman although I
would love to run down the beach you
know why can't I have that why can't I
have happiness alright let's let's pick
one one of each
all right is there any girl I just
wanted who's a shut the [ __ ] up I would
say back in the day it would have been
Madonna but like she would just she was
like beyond annoys she was so [ __ ]
annoying she was like I would just want
to get out of the room you know what I
mean he always watches that Blonde
Ambition Tour and there's nothing more
nauseating than watching somebody who's
surrounded by yes men you know I mean
they just completely [ __ ] obnoxious
everything they say everyone's hanging
all over every word and they just
laughing at everything like that's you
know something that's one thing that I
have learned in this business is a major
red flag is somebody who has an
entourage if you have an entourage like
I don't know I've already I
automatically judge you as like alright
this person is it's not somebody I'm
gonna want to [ __ ] be around because
the only way I'm going to be able to
exist is this I assimilate into your
entourage and when you tell the joke
that isn't funny I can't be like I can't
look at you like that joke sucks I have
to [ __ ] do like what they're doing
you know laugh my ass off cuz you're
paying for my hotel room with the [ __ ]
out of here right that and and people
who don't hang out with Pierce you know
maybe they don't have an entourage but
everybody they hang out with is [ __ ]
like ten years behind them in this
business then that's another that's
another red flag because then nobody's
calling you out on your [ __ ] right
that's that's how I look at it how did I
get to that with this [ __ ] you know I'm
gonna have to get back to you on this
one you know I'm a [ __ ] 44 year old
guy so I don't really sit you know when
I was younger I had my I'll go back in
the day my list okay when I was a kid
the Bionic Woman
all three Charlie's Angels Farrah I
wanted to bang I had lust for her Kate
Jackson I would marry and Jaclyn Smith
you know it's your fault for standing
between the two of them see you're going
down too but you know I didn't need
Jaclyn Smith cuz I already had the
brunette with with [ __ ]
Kate Jackson um then who else who else
in the 80s I like what's her face the
replacement for Shelley long was in the
look who's talking she came on had that
horse smoky force he [ __ ] smoky voice
whatever [ __ ] he's supposed to say it's
supposed to sound way more sexier than
that she had nice [ __ ] curves got a
little out of control there after a
while but you know she still has nice
hips I gotta tell you uh who else you
know it's weird Florence Henderson when
she had the worst mullet haircut always
turned me on more than when she had that
awful [ __ ] Oh Marsha of Marcia Brady
when she [ __ ] had the little short
skirts on [ __ ] Janet Jackson when she
was on Diff'rent Strokes who else I just
it goes on for [ __ ] ever I just can't
remember anymore
there's never Cyndi Lauper I could tell
you that she did seem like some spaz
little [ __ ] boy to me yeah and then
that [ __ ] the haircut that she had
was she [ __ ] had like a tic-tac-toe
board on the side of her head that just
really freaked me out
not that I was totally against that
haircut because I thought that chicken
bow-wow-wow I thought she was hot who
the [ __ ] else but I like Lita Ford oh my
god did I like her I think I might have
somebody back then I can't [ __ ]
remember anyways is that the podcast can
I end on possibly liking Lita Ford
alright if you had to bang any of the
Runaways who would you bang I would have
said Pat Benatar cuz she was the hottest
but just you know knowing that she
didn't really want to do it
you know I believe that that would be
awful maybe get tag-team another chick
with her I don't [ __ ] know all right
listen this is I got [ __ ] to do this is
the podcast for this week I apologize
for it being so damn late keep the
emails coming and I'll keep doing the
podcast I guarantee you next week's
podcast I will be doing Sunday night so
it's ready for Monday morning even on
the East Coast just to make it up for
you this is my I apologize that I beat
you last night all right that's it
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you next week
you